hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the most interesting discussions
that st. Augustine engages in in his
City of God book 19 has to do with peace
and what we can call a universal and an
annex Punja ball
desire for peace even among those who
seem to be opposed to it those who don't
want peace those who are engaging in
conflict all of them he says actually do
on some level and in some way desire
peace and often this means that they
desire a peace in the way that they
conceive of it as being good even though
it may not in fact be good in a full
sense so he tells us that every person
every human being and as a matter of
fact he'll tell us that other animals
too every human being desires peace so
this raises a question right away well
what about those people who seem prone
to conflict those who like to stir stuff
up those who seem to thrive on drama and
what Augustine says can apply just as
well to them as to the people that he
talks about who are a little bit more
familiar in his own time those who wage
war he says that what they all really do
desire is some kind of peace but it's on
their terms so when a country wants to
invade another country as was happening
with Rome all the time or when there's
civil war going on or when there's
barbarians invading and taking over what
is it that they really want they want
the things perhaps or they want to enjoy
the activity of engaging in conflict but
what they ultimately want is for their
needs to be met for them to get the
other things that they desire and to be
secure in them you take over territory
so that you can can
trol that territory now you may do that
by subordinating those people or as
often happened in ancient times by
taking the people off that land and
sending them somewhere else and bringing
in your own colonists but the reason why
you're doing that is so that you can
have peace on your own terms he also
talks about those who are fighting as
desiring peace with glory with fame you
know you might think of the Romans and
figures like Pompey who just driven by
the need for public honors that they
called triumph
you got those after the war was finished
and if you think about it in a much more
mundane level thinking about personal
life you know the kind of people who as
we say like to stir things up what is it
that they're actually doing they're
trying to bring about a new state of
affairs that is more amenable to them
people engage in conflict because they
want to produce a different kind of
peace than whatever it is that they're
currently with it so they desire peace
on their own terms and Augustine
considers some other objections as well
you might say well that's fine but what
about people who actually tear the
fabric of society apart what about say
co-conspirators who are engaging in some
sort of faction or a revolution or plot
what about bands of criminals or pirates
there were pirates in his own time
robbers people who prey upon other
people and he says well you're right
they are not respecting peace in society
as such but they do in fact still need
to maintain peace among their own
membership so Augustine would say yes
there does in fact have to be some honor
among thieves if they're going to remain
thieves very long and insofar as the
things break down between them the
relationships
expectations the structure of authority
they won't have peace and they won't be
effective in order to actually be
effective as some sort of organization
in order to impose force upon others and
cause them to fear and give up their
wallets or whatever it else that is that
you're trying to get there they're you
know money their food their Liberty
anything it happens to be you have to be
able to unify and you can only unify if
there's some sort of lasting peace among
the members once that disappears they
break down and when we do see this that
one of the ways in which criminal
organizations or subversive
organizations wind up being taken out is
they get turned against each other they
come into conflict with each other
the peace ceases at that point says what
about an that's fine put that aside
think about some guy who's so strong so
terrifying that he can do it all on his
own he's got no interest in lining up
with any Confederates or associates he's
gonna go out there and rape and murder
and rob all by himself
Augustine says well even that guy is
looking for some sort of shadow of peace
insofar as he conceals his activity to
any extent he's trying to maintain some
sort of peace between himself and the
rest of the world well let's assume that
he doesn't do that audience says what
happens when he goes home does he behave
towards his wife and children in that
very same way does he terrorize them and
I see and says well maybe he does but if
he does that it's because he is
attempting to impose some sort of peace
upon his own household and he goes so
far as to suggest that perhaps if an
individual like this were given an
entire country to rule he would rule it
like his own household that is badly and
tyrannical but within a an effort and an
intention of imposing some sort of
peace on his own terms some sort of
harmony what little harmony there can be
with people who you've made afraid of
you through threats and force and and
punishments and things like that but
there is still some vestige of peace
there Augustine then goes a little bit
further he says now there isn't any
actual person like this but let's say
that there was something let's do a
thought experiment there was some guy
will call him Kakos which simply means
the bad guy in ancient Greek right so
he's just badness itself he doesn't have
a wife or kids as a matter of fact he
doesn't even want that sort of thing he
just preys upon everybody he comes
across he's worse than the Cyclops of
antiquity who at least had some sort of
social life among them and perhaps their
own wife and children that they would
dominate right Kakos is just thoroughly
bad Augustine says well that guy still
wants some kind of peace he doesn't want
peace with anybody else
as a matter of fact he wants to kill
them but he does want peace with the
members of his own body he doesn't want
his stomach not digesting the stuff that
he puts in it he wants his limbs to do
the things that he wants them to do you
know he could say that the famous line
feet don't fail me now feet maintain
peace by actually doing what it is that
I tell you to do right or he might say
club hands don't fail me now as I'm
clubbing somebody we could go on and on
the point here is that even Kakos who
Augustine doesn't think really exists
but we might think there are some people
that thoroughly bad even he still wants
to maintain some sort of integrity and
some sort of harmony with some
association that of his bodily members
now Augustine does tell us a few other
things about this notion of peace and
deep desire for it that are particularly
important and he talks about the
difference between a just peace and an
unjust peace an unjust peace does
involve trying to have peace on one's
own terms
peace that will seem peaceful for
oneself but will not seem peaceful for
those who are subordinated those who are
exploited those who are dominated those
who are in some way done in but it does
at least participate to some degree in
what a just peace would look like which
would be an equitable distribution now
Augustine is talking within a Christian
framework so he thinks of this just
peace ultimately in terms of an
orientation towards the divine towards
God towards some sort of law or
structure a norm moral structure under
which everybody would live and under
which everybody would get what they
deserve and they would treat each other
equitably we have a wide range of course
don't we between the completely unjust
which is almost a borderline condition
that can't really exist and the fully
just which would be living within this
divine arrangement but we can have a
just peace versus an unjust peace
Augustine tells us that an unjust peace
is driven and desired because of the
vices of a person or persons and he uses
the example of pride but we might be
able to think of many others as well
you could take the seven deadly sins
which Augustine himself does not of
course discuss in his works but other
Christian authors did and bring some of
those in could we have people who
attempt to impose an unjust peace
because of the more bodily sins of lust
or gluttony certainly they attempt to
maintain arrangements that fit them
quite well you might think of all the
revelations that have come about
to the me2 movement of horrible things
that people have been doing for decades
and getting away with driven by lust
perhaps also driven by pride and other
things as well but certainly taking that
form because of that telling somebody
that if they don't go along with you
because if they reveal it they'll be
fired and sued so they better get in
line you know with with the policies
never written policies or even procure
you further victims that would be a
perfect example of an unjust piece from
Augustine's perspective and it's driven
by vices now insofar as there's some
sort of social arrangement being sought
out some sort of piece being produced
it's not completely bad because it's
impossible for something to be
thoroughly completely no trace of good
whatsoever but the badness is
parasitical upon the goodness in cases
like this and Augustine has a very nice
passage here where he talks about the
person who prefers what is right to what
is wrong now that already excludes many
people there are many human beings in
this world and there are many people in
Augustine's own time who do in fact
prefer what is wrong to what is right
and may have told themselves that what
they're preferring is actually right
when it indeed it is wrong this is going
on you know and pretty much every
culture we look at their moral
literature so he says he who prefers
what is right to what is wrong and then
the next key phrase what is well ordered
to what is perverted what he means
thereby perverted we we often think
about this solely in a sexual context
when you see that term you should think
about its original meaning turned away
turned aside turned in the wrong
direction so what is good has been
perverted or corrupted for something
wrong something evil a person who
prefers what is well ordered where
things are actually given their right
place
their proper orientations and placed
into perspective with each other as
opposed to someone who's driven by what
is perverted again say the desire to
dominate others will recognize he says
that the Peace of unjust men is not
worthy to be called peace in comparison
with the Peace of the just but even what
is perverted must of necessity says be
in harmony with and in dependence on and
in some part of the order of things for
otherwise it would have no existence at
all so what we find is that that
everybody every single thing even
animals he talks about savage beasts you
know at least taking care of their their
young and their own kind
everything desires some sort of peace
but it's very easy to get mistaken about
what a good whatuh just what a proper
peace looks like and instead to allow it
to slip into a peace that we might find
more congenial but other beings won't
because it's not a just peace
so Augustine wants us to recognize the
difference between these and the fact
that we could actually move from a
desire for an unjust peace to a properly
ordered desire for a just peace
you